[Music]
you got some very talented girls to
having fun uh no one
Molly both I stay all the way like I
like to let the girls they do their
thing and you know if they want or need
me they know that I'm always there and
Miley has an incredible island album
coming out oh man I'm so excited about
this album
Miley really leaned into her roots with
this new album Malibu in particular
which the LA song de Leon I hear a lot
of influences from the Beach Boys
John Cash Waylon obviously dolly there's
a lot of influences in Molly's roots
even down just to some of the sounds of
Lynyrd Skynyrd I mean the sounds that
were roaring out of our house and the
people that was coming through our house
it King who wrote Sweet Home Alabama was
frequently at the house if you really
want to know my league this record is a
great place to start her look is so
different you have a preference of one
way or the other way you know what I
like about the way she looks happy I'm
her daddy she's beaming with happiness
that means more to me than anything
that's what I want Molly to look like
happy Molly was very real hugs now she
had cleaned up at Jenn uh Denny drugs in
the past few weeks and he notice the
difference and how does it make you feel
sad I don't know how to break it down
more than just the fact I see a joy in
her spirit and something coming from
within that is just pure beauty if you
will how do you think that that's
because she's so happy
she doesn't need to she's firing on all
cylinders man like her instincts mm-hmm
everything is like at the top of its
game I can't point a finger you know one
way or another sometimes you just got to
clear out the junk you know what I mean
and then you realize what's most
important whatever's going on man like
it's working for her cuz she is like
again happy that's the main thing you
should do like
a trio with you should do like you know
everybody says a duet but like to do a
trio between you and Noah and Miley
we've been talking about some toys and
things there's there's a lot of great
ideas
[Music]
you